still got a great face
what if you had teeth man I missed my
freaking
uh
uh corn nuts
you can't chew A Corn Nut without teeth
no
and it's weird uh there's been just been
flaking off I don't do meth which
usually that's what freaking I see
people with their teeth are all dead and
stuff they're all gone yeah
yeah Quinn uh where'd you where'd you
grow up where are you from
well born and raised born in Santa
Monica I was raised in a town called
Simi Valley
which is like six miles long at the
widest point it's a mile
remember at one point a lot of fires and
a whole ring around the whole freaking
Valley when I was a kid that was a trip
but uh yeah so I was raised and ran
cross country in school
did everything but tennis
which I hear you do but
uh
mom that was a black sheep
12 years old I stole the off-duty Cops
car
I ran into an off-duty Cops car and I
stopped in front of an off-duty cops
house
my mom said bro when you [__] up you
[__] up
oh excuse me
what was your childhood like
all of my mom's punching bag
she was she was me she was a violent one
she drank
uh it wouldn't let it be a cop that
really pissed off because she had
something on her jacket her mental
go figure
uh so she came to private security
people and she made like a up in that
Lieutenant captain or something
she
to train my Dobies attack dogs
I didn't keep everything up boy
took it out on me
we came up from school one day with a
fat lip because uh first time I
experienced somebody
uh bullying a handicap for
didn't seem right sorry it's got in the
middle told the guy to run dude hit me
mom said what happened to you I said
told her I said oh no oh no
pridefulness
taught me how to fight
put us all in karate when I picked it up
too quick she took me out of it
and if you know she came home
someone called her they got a fight too
why'd you hit that guy so damn hard he's
in another Street almost getting hit by
cars
remember a month later came home from
school she was gone
house was empty my three older siblings
were already out married with kids sent
my little brother to my dad's house
you didn't even didn't even bother me
three years later I remember
it's like
God damn I'm slow I guess but three
years later
and I thought about it
started crying
then it went away
20 years later I said damn my mom left
me
[__] happens that's the way I just been
living so it happens
is your dad in your life
uh he was a guy
that came by in a brown Ford pickup and
bought his shoes
and clothes
I remember when I went to visit at one
time
he had a lawnmower power lawnmower and a
push lawn mower and I grabbed the push
one started doing the line
he's watching me it's the sun we have
this one
I said yeah but this one's funner and I
could smell the grass
and he goes so come here he goes you're
you're you're a boy you're going to be a
man you're going to work the rest of
your life you should learn to love it
I didn't know what love was I thought it
was like like so when I was growing up
we'd force myself to like things like it
well my mom left or try to do school and
work at the same time the grades were
suffering and I was too tired at work
because of the hours
quit school
started framing houses
what did you quit school
when that was great uh
tenth
is that great
my best friend's parents took me in as a
legal guardian even
and he even said he's got no problem
you're working he says this would be
great suffer not to quit work
well I did the opposite I quit school
but I went back to a community college
in Pensacola Florida
and uh got my diploma
which was surprised me they said I got
the highest score they've seen in the
school
I've always loved academics and it was
easy I'd miss a lot of
because I was stoned all the time I I
missed
during the week but they're not the
tests I picked it up and still did it
but
that part just I mean one thing I really
wish my dad would have done was to
encourage me to
follow through
because it didn't exist
and right now it barely does
I just
sometimes I think about my mom but I'll
just piss me off
because she never encouraged I never got
a hug from her I used to draw all the
time I got brought home straight a
straight A's was
almost 30 student every every year and
she said
you know what happens if you didn't get
that
that encouraged me to do it I guess
in the wrong way
but I my Dad loved boxing my mom loves
the martial artists I wanted kickboxing
try to meet him halfway you know what I
mean
she said just kickboxing for [__]
that's what I got
but then she hit me in the Shins with
the bamboo to make sure I [__] did it
right she said if you're gonna do it
you're gonna do it right all you want to
do is bring pain
well things like on her best friend but
anyway what I'm doing down here is uh
I had moved to Georgia
actually I went to visit friends in
Georgia I ended up staying because of
the work
because it's totally different oh my God
people wave at you with open hand as
opposed to one finger
and it's sincerely concerned about you
oh
it's working uh flipping houses
uh I was too new over there couldn't get
really much work so I was working for a
guide up in the foreman
Essen s m
construction Sarah
and Michelle was or Melissa her kid's
name abbreviated the title anyway so
busy that we couldn't even do his own
roof
subcontracted it out he calls me I'm I'm
driving home I already had three beers
in me had my logging boots on because on
the track go clearing the land because
he'd buy land he'd clear it grade it
bring it in for a new house and make
some good money
I shouldn't have been on the roof he's
called me so they didn't dry it in which
is they didn't put the plastic nor the
the felt paper
and storms there coming come and go in
15 minutes and don't more more rain in
15 minutes than this play season a year
I said okay call so and so I'll be there
in a minute
you're up on that roof two wraps around
doing the Ridge Top ridge cap had my
corner I'm shaking it off still had the
damn logging boots on with no grip for
incline the 10 on 12 pitch real steep
stuck on the plastic started sliding it
was sliding so fast I couldn't grab my
hammer in time to slam it in the wood
and save me
so only way I was thinking all the way
down this is gonna hurt It's Gonna Hurt
it's gonna hurt because it stings the
feet when you land on them
I don't know if he rolled kept getting
up kept falling what the hell people
stopped by because they saw me fall
I kept falling and touching my head for
blood nothing sat down on a freaking
still look down my knees straight but my
legs my foot's this way
shattered my leg
uh Staffing like I said in from the
place because they had to put an
external fixator it was shattered
Staffing back to set in it rotted
everything on my ankle
they end up having to scrape to Grizzle
out between my ankle bones
and Infused it
I told them
I'm a Motorhead I taught myself
mechanics love racing
but I've
rotisserie cars
uh
they lied to me they said it was going
to be okay I said if not cut it off I
was watching a NASCAR inside the
hospital I was under 30 minute 30 days
just for the infection
and I was watching NASCAR and I zoomed
in on it and then it went like that and
they panned out and it was a guy with a
prosthetic they had the NASCAR he had a
custom one with a NASCAR emblem on it I
thought it was so cool and I thought
about it and then I was reading a lot of
magazines in there and these guys with
double amputations were rock climbing
still all kinds of stuff
and I said
tell you what cut this thing off if it's
going to be a problem seriously why
would you want to do that I said because
I have a life
I do construction I need to walk that
top plate I needed to do the joist I
need to do this this is what I do and I
run across country I need this to work
it will it will I said if it's not cut
off seriously please cut it off it is
going to be a problem
he said it's not okay
the day they were going to sign out
Ms Hernandez uh we wanted me to talk to
you you may want to sit down I said for
what
uh you have to find another way to
support yourself so what are you talking
about
they said you're gonna
you're not gonna be able to to use that
leg anymore like like you need to I said
why'd you guys
not cut it off I told you I get used to
a prosthetic sooner
they're quite likelihood away
took my heart away
of the Full Throttle guy everything I
did
has loved to run it was a mental therapy
it couldn't work
even when they start the wound back on
me
she's on the internet
halfway to get a a grant from the from
the state
for truck driving my dad did it my
brother did it my brother-in-law did it
my Grandpa did it
I knew I was gonna be able to do it
because I smoked pot all the time in the
test
so I said okay let's do this
and it's what I do at your construction
and I cuss in a custom designed I
designed his bathroom and if idiots
couldn't do it right
it's like going there out of the
wheelchair on crutches I take the wound
back up tight around my neck or my ankle
and then they're setting the tile
cutting and cutting and finished it
and I lagged on the on the Grant I lost
it
[Music]
ballet
California said that I expounded what's
that called when you run X
when they say when you got a expound or
something anyway I didn't check in they
said I said I did three years of that
parole
don't tell me that
and because they uh what it was one of
the houses I was doing the guy partial
pay was like oh man beautiful 1967
Marlin lever action uh 30 odd six oh my
gosh beautiful hunting rifle and I knew
I wasn't supposed to have I thought I
was handguns for concealed they said you
can't have any firearms and I thought it
was for handguns because he grew up like
you got to go into a place with a
freaking rifle but I guess in the South
Miami it's normal people walk around
that crap
wanting to get cleaned
next thing I know a detective showed up
to when I was and I got married
a Christian
oh my God how he did that was amazing
I was Christian and uh married a
southern belle redhead petite
she was in the choir and I was there
three months in series every day and all
of a sudden poof my eyes opened up to
her
well
we met in a marriage she already had
three kids not having any
when that came up I said I don't know
what it is what it's for what it's for
you know they were
they said uh well what it was is he said
okay that's what happened we need to
talk came in anyway while they said it
she had to get uh you have to do some
time
you're not supposed to have it I said
okay I ended up doing 28 days which
usually it took two and a half months
over there just to get to court
well I know the Lord's handles on that
got me in rushed and then she kept
asking questions what is it what is it
what is it they said they wanted to hold
me because the California said they had
an award for me
well they ended up having me come back
in they arrested me and then when I was
in jail just she asked me for a divorce
because she said I was lying to her
which I said I don't know what it is I
don't know what it is the judge even
there didn't even know they would even
tell Georgia what it was about
they came and got me extradite me from
over there to here
my life was wasted anyway so it's not
like I lost anything
what it was the parole officer was using
mess
me and two other guys
she reported her notification how she
ever she noted everything down
was incomplete so me and two other guys
had to do our parole over
three years
over again
so when I got out I went to a place
called a a old Queen of Angels hospital
called The Dream Center
once you discipleship there
uh
again because I had gone through it
before I had left
uh anyhow
I went there because my instruction
skills
my skin grass and stuff that I kept
wearing holes
doing construction there because high
tops of War kept wearing holes in my
skin graft
while I was there they had to take a
muscle from here put her down here for
circulation three Skin grafts three
attempts that Bonnie took
that was another one that was another 30
days inside the hospital oh and then
anyhow
so I come back over here do it nothing
happened oh my gosh that's the mechanic
talking about mechanics they asked me
they used to have a bus Ministry
took it from construction
saying will you help him to get the each
year to go to Arizona Phoenix
I said okay that means it has to go out
campus had to rent a place
a month later
they kill the bus Ministry
and then there's they have a thing
saying when you leave campus you can't
come back for six months then you come
back on
well they said I couldn't come back for
six months I said wait a minute you guys
asked me to do this and then you cut it
and then now I'm asking to come back
because you asked me to leave campus
well it's still we got to hold it in six
months
I said I knew this was Hollywood Church
the period so much appearance
anyway that left me on the street I
enjoy
girl my cousin
got my license drive trucks I was
driving trucks
also uh Maxima in the Yukon I didn't
want to pay insurance for both
and we hold pick up cars from all the
places and we're down in in San Diego
and like every time I get a call I
couldn't get there in time to meet the
person to sell the car
15 is bad coming back up anyway didn't
make Elsinore get it I'm in the maximum
turn to screw them you want to take it
to pick apart in Ontario I'm sitting I'm
going I know I'm going 75 it was 70
there
somebody cuts me off a wave like that
come back in my Lane CHP pulls me over
you know I have insurance on it he goes
well bring the card in he says it'll
take most of the the payment away
go to court
it only took off like 300 it was an 1800
ticket
speeding unsafe rate change no insurance
as well Wells Fargo my bank great Wells
Fargo
yeah I think I make payments because I'm
bad not too good at making payments so I
need my license and I didn't want to
lose it
had them do it they were late with one
payment Riverside County suspended in my
class a commercial license
I couldn't drive my cousin anymore he's
letting me know that ahead of time so
apply in other places
got it back and forth East Coast with
this company he said he liked me says
I'm hired the day I I go to drive for
him as a full-time driver he's calling
me saying hey man you know your license
suspended and he has a he has a sense of
humor like I do and I thought he was a
joke I said man on the 15 I'm getting
down there I'll be there in a couple
minutes boo
I get there he says seriously he gets on
the internet hello
look this is suspended I said what it
goes in insufficient funds this is what
are delinquent uh funds is you're
kidding me
and they said yeah in order to get my
license back
[Music]
they said I had to pay it all in full
it was 800 left on it
and all I had left saved was enough for
one month's rent insurance for my for my
Yukon I said something will come I was
doing side work
construction and or mechanic
nothing came
call my brother and said man uh I'm
living on this property I got a trailer
here it's like 25 acres beautiful in
between Lake Elsinore and Hemet
there we go okay trailer I could have
some room come there I need help I need
help this is okay I was gonna drive out
there pay for everything and bring it
back
last minute he dicks out oh man we're
gonna get you where you throw a fit I
don't throw a fit let's get mad because
yeah your mom got so much light I don't
know
that load up my car my tools mechanic
and construction tools my cousin told me
about this place they had a lot of food
things are cheap down here
hmm okay so guess what I gotta do
come here
that'll tell us right across the street
three days later
my truck is is towed
they said it was from street sweeping I
said look it's the wrong day I took a
picture of the phone said uh well get a
lawyer so I can't afford a lawyer but we
don't talk to lawyers
it ended up being a
bogus
company that the city has subcontracted
for them
and now they don't use it anymore about
three or four months after that they
stopped using because of that and the
police said I had to get a lawyer also
so I lost my vehicle
literally a week after that I had got
everything out of my car because I kept
a lot of in it and covered it literally
a week after that I put everything in my
room up here it got broken in supposedly
broken
everything was gone
just afford it
was wrong no SSI here nothing
you're on the street
or the first night there used to be an
ice place over there on Industrial in
Alameda
on that deck I remember the first thing
all my clothes literally my clothes are
gone too I had a shirt down to here I'll
leaned up against one of the posts yeah
I put my arms to the side like this
and it said in the first time of
homeless with nothing literally nothing
and then oh yeah I forgot to tell y'all
been doing Cokes themselves like 18.
Maryland when Rock came in I learned to
cook it
that was it
alcohol even got to put aside for that
crap
I thought it was functional but
yeah work suffered almost [__] ran
over people actually delivered Furniture
being so tired falling asleep at the
wheel
there's still nothing set in
here continued
I'd quit for a while
but it's like he's a friend I guess
a friend that stabs you in the back
up and down up and down while here just
got worse and better to do
pallets work
a lot of the people the places that they
tear down and put up new or renovate
I'd go in there and
borrow copper permanently
of caught up outside of one building one
time
mainly to get my fix
and the drain pipes they're pretty sick
that they put on some of these old
buildings as opposed with those thin tin
ones
not thinking
the mouse bracket that holds it
they're they're at an age they'd rusted
like this using like this the pressure
from the building my hands like this all
of a sudden I move at the top
it looks like I interact it was right
before I go to reach
the bracket goes like this and at that
balance point I don't know if anybody's
ever felt that or it's like your stomach
goes up and you're gonna go or you're
not it just stopped
and I'm four stories up
that would have been flat white
went down the next one
window seal
down to the fire escape
didn't do nothing to me
about another way in
come down here
they uh
don't have a friend down here
no one I consider friends
everybody says yeah watch your stuff
they're the one that get in it say oh I
left for a moment left for a moment
fights
what I'm in this area
literally for the first three years
three flights a day
literally three fights a day
it's like my mom honed me for this
[Music]
those of you who like your moms sorry
yeah
just for instance a little a couple
minutes ago talking with this dude
so they're just unintentionally just
literally right here it comes like the
end so yeah
no concern no no desire to even respect
anybody doesn't exist down here
how many years you've been down here 10
years
I remember this dude they call he comes
up mayor I forgot his name he's white
and he's got his little beard and uh he
walks around like he owns the place
that's what causes a mayor
I remember when I was here I was there
barely a year and I said dude how long
have you been he goes 10 years like he's
proud of it I'm like dude why are you
homing for 10 years
or how is it that you can be homeless
for 10 years
you have to you have to survive one way
or another
I thought the deal was nuts
well I must be nuts because now I'm 10
years
why the [__] attitude
wanting the next heads
drinking I'm gonna drink it's just like
ah [__] it
the [__] your attitude is kept me here
what's your biggest regret
not telling about my lover
and I've seen in movies and stuff people
tattoos moms
diced through it or flying through it or
something
I just didn't I didn't know my mom was
one that just fed me
so like
nothing just
about pain or emotional physical
food shelter
know nothing about it other than that
my dad
so the only thing you ever said to me
was about the work
my brothers Satan my older brother
guys is just just mean as hell
and it all those thoughts sometimes come
up with us when I drink they come up and
it just doesn't end
it's like a revolving door is cycling
it's a [__] attitude isn't it
people see me and they say why are you
here you know you seem to have a sense
of course in my freaking stupid assets
of humor I said no I got a dollar
they're sort of laughed but
I just don't
the encouragement to follow through
apart
I mean I got it to encourage people with
it say this or that
when I'm working Nothing Stops me at
that point it's got to get done gotta
get done
I remember oh my gosh
I have a C5 license when I first did it
concrete Masonry
my first estimate of seven thousand
dollars off but I had to do a contract
so I had to eat it because I signed the
contract
seven thousand
you think that might Rings the red flags
out not
I might joke around with this I tell
people I think I got Dane Brandman from
birth he said what oh I mean brain
damage
yeah
how do you support yourself if you're
still using crack
I'm not a battery guy around here
car batteries truck batteries
there's nothing to ever to be proud of
but I don't do from
no disrespect
for small people
businesses because they can absorb it
not that they should
but it's easier for them than somebody
else and save my shoes
kind of one of the hardest things to
think out here
was a lack of something in someone's
heart
and your mentality
if something's still from a homeless
person but a sleeping homeless person
laughs
I just it is Wrecking something inside
that person's struggling so freaking
hard and it has
those vulnerable state
it's like that person earlier just don't
just say it doesn't succeed or nothing
doesn't care
got nothing to do that even a woman I
saw a woman that was sleeping in her
personal certain
guys just trying to be all [__] taking
her freaking curse
what I do is any better no
let me proud of it
but it gives me my two two liter bottles
of soda a day and three packs of cookies
I'm a sugar fanatic I mean the hyper
since I was a kid
oh yeah I mentioned my alcohol my rock
it doesn't even do it anymore but yet I
still chasing it
alcohol always does
matter of fact that's what I was going
to get I was going to get a beer when I
saw you you see these alcohol your go-to
or is correct no
it's getting more alcohol again because
it's weird it's just not I guess the
body ain't making the dopamine that the
coke releases I guess
but one of the things also is the
partial paralysis is getting worse and I
got that because about the third year I
was here I got jumped by gang members
because they couldn't it couldn't scare
me they couldn't
um
you know when you intimidate me thanks
to Ma
I was in this veterans places half
veterans have homeless over there a
Crocker and it was infiltrated with the
drug dealers they're the people that ran
the place let them keep their stuff in
there you know the bulk of it what a guy
thought this [__] didn't stink and I'm
gonna mopping the floor this box right
in it and walks out of the dude at least
you could wait till it's somewhat dry
and then I finish up I come back and
he's standing he's sitting on my
freaking bed like dude you're going to
want to move
and it didn't he stood up and got my
face like that boom
he got up next thing I know I see him
looking at me like this and then his
eyes moved and then when I went like
that all I saw was yellow and it was a
mop ringer
some people from behind and then they
continue to stop me I woke up three days
later in the hospital
and uh
I have reconstructive surgery I've got
stainless steel mesh in here
and uh
this eye was lower you know they had to
do a bunch of [__] but it's partial
paralysis because when they put the
metal in they cut some nerves and stuff
so it's either the uh the dopamine is
not being produced as much as it used to
or the the parts for us is going because
now I can't even hit the pipe right now
but yet it's still trying
I don't think I can still [__] drink
from the bottle damn good
well a lot of it gets down on this
I just don't know
I don't feel stuck
mainly because it's my own
making my own doing
and I keep stinking
just because my dad didn't see it I mean
a lot of people the parents the dad is
the one that teaches this and that and
the mom just
little borrows keeps them in line but
didn't get jacked and there's a lot of
people that have been in my situation
and yet they
faith
something that's got to be something
better than this
do you think not having a dad in your
life was
one of the reasons you're here
I don't know maybe I'm making it one of
the reasons
I just
I miss them I didn't know oh five
oh my gosh when I was married with Cindy
cute as you sweetie
I miss her
see ya
within a month I lost my dad she lost
her mom
brought us closer that's why I went
when that happened with the saint I
expounded
she said I was lying she couldn't
believe that I was lying and I'm not I'm
not lying I'm not lying
so
I don't know I just
I don't know it's got to be me
my actions lack of actions proper
actions
I mean I've had hired jobs down here
if it doesn't have interest to me it
I'd do it but then and then honestly you
know what nah
what's your biggest fear now
fear
of
oh the future like what are you afraid
of happening
I don't know I don't
I'm concerned about
that fentanyl crap
because it can be put in anything it
looks like crack Yeah well yeah why
would you crack it's mostly a synthetic
heroin in their opposite ends the ones
up on the downer
and that's another thing the people who
do it on purpose some you still know how
to do it and then people are putting it
in on purpose
to me is makes sense
one's an upper one's a downer why would
you put a downer
in the upper only one reason is to kill
people
I mean people are doing the uh and some
they're not I didn't know you could do
it myself I said well how do you do that
if it's so strong well it's because they
dilute it you know whatever
Our concern is
so I'm never gonna see my sister again
Laura
Bishops
I don't want to die without saying that
lover again
nor her kids
and yet
all the effort I put into feeding my
part of the alcohol in the rock
I don't want to do that just trying to
find her
to communicate with her
son
her husband's [__] and it's not
paying child support in
that she she had so much she did by
herself
and I'm in this I just freaking the
other day the other night
why Amanda why am I still here
oh yeah
teaching oh yeah
I don't want this anymore it keeps I've
been saying so much since that last
month I don't want this anymore
but it's my actions that are keeping me
here
that makes me angry that I know there's
[__] out here so when I'm angry
that's when I'm drinking
I go looking for it and I find it
I don't start anything I just wait
someone's gonna start
I don't like hurting people
just became good at it
I don't start [__] I just finish it
you're down here
perfect place for that
sometimes I feel like
my mom told me for this like somehow
unknownly or when she knew and did it
and
but don't get intimidated I mean when he
said fear I'm like yeah I guess fear
of something not you know concerned of
falling off a building or getting run
over by these cars
drag strip oh my God Alameda or right
there on Central and between 7th and
eighth is a drag strip right next to the
produce place I should stay there right
in front of uh the uh the candy place
and uh
people been hit there I
it's amazing to see people
die in front of you and die while you're
talking with him
that would break your ass up
all right
Glenn what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
practically
a practical one
what is the lesson or not I've seen when
this skills that I've learned because it
can it should be doing it right now and
keep me alive
helping other people with it
the lesson is something that you've gone
through and then you learned from
I was going to say I'm just going to say
don't trust anybody but I can't
I have to I do
uh
lesson
well one of them just
when somebody's an [__] to you just
don't crack them
because they come back with three or
four
proceeds they are
um
practical I should be saying what
alcohol has done
but I only got one DUI that that's not
the thing is alcohol bad it is and all
the [__] that I've been through for it
the Rock
all the [__] I've done to feed it
there's things I've lost the people that
I pushed away
but they're they're learning from that
have I apparently not
do I want to yeah
I want to learn from that just as bad as
I want to hit does that make any sense
oxy freaking [__]
what's that called catch 20 catch 422
yeah
pickle
I'm wearing baseball stuck only in one
of those
dig it out of it
I guess I want to say this
lesson is to
to not assume everybody's the same down
here has taught me to uh lots of
be humble because I guess that was in a
sense
but to know doesn't it's the person not
the situation they're in or what they
have or don't have
this place has allowed me to see in a
different way
to care for people more so than I did
before
the lack there it has said I don't care
for myself
and being sober right now whether it's
long enough to for [__] to work in the
head for me to acknowledge it to accept
it and do something about it
like right now it's just
I was going to get a beer
to call it my breakfast champion
I don't want this anymore
because if we had a Benjamin lesson to
teach me to
to leave
to do something about it apparently not
I want to learn but have I I don't want
this anymore but yeah that's still here
all right Quinn thank you so much for
sharing your story you're welcome wish
you the best of luck out here
thank you